[Music]
on this Friday night horrifying memories
of a heinous crime a stunned witness on
what happened moments before two
Edmonton constables were killed before I
even went back into my apartment I heard
shooting what could be causing the rise
in violence against police
temporary Top Cop
as the rcmp's new boss and questions
about one
of the commissioner will be named
another American Bank on the brink
bailed out the uncertainty for nervous
investors
fighter jets on the way Ukraine gets
what it wanted as Russia's president
becomes a wanted man plus proud to be
pint-sized 143.8 square feet inside
Canada's smallest bar
global national with baronessor
good evening and thank you for joining
us we're learning heartbreaking new
details about the lives and deaths of
two young Edmonton police officers
constables Brett Ryan and Travis Jordan
responded to a call about a family
dispute early Thursday morning when they
were gunned down police say the officers
didn't even have an opportunity to
respond to the threat that faced them
Heather York's West has our top story
tonight
from across the street Linda felstead
could see something terrible unfolding
in her North Edmonton neighborhood two
policemen were carrying out a man and we
thought it was one of the a bad man that
they had
like tied up he was all crunched up and
they put him in the back seat of a
police car and they took off beltstead
would later learn that the men she saw
being carried out of the apartment
complex were constables Brett Ryan and
Travis Jordan police officers that
neighbor Philip Dunn had spoken with
just moments before they turned off on
the second floor behind me and then
before I even went back into my
apartment I heard shooting the gunman
according to police was just 16 living
with his father and mother a struggle
reportedly ensued between the mother and
son over the firearm and the mother was
shot
the suspect then turned the firearm on
himself taking his own life
in a tribute to her son posted on social
media Lori Ryan shared that Corporal
Brett Ryan loved his wife an unborn baby
we have been blessed to have you for the
past 30 years she wrote but today your
loss is unbearable
with the murders of Ryan and Jordan
Canada has seen seven line of duty
deaths in as many months and
criminologist Daniel Jones has a theory
on what could be to blame when the
police are seen as legitimate power
holders I think they've seen legitimate
is in the community
violence against police happens less so
the more we reduce police legitimacy
potentially the more violence that
happens against police officers and
there's a whole bunch of research behind
that
following the murder of George Floyd in
2020 the use of force by police was
scrutinized like never before and there
have been calls to reform and even
defund Police Services worldwide and I'm
not saying policing doesn't need reform
or change because it does
but are the members on the front line
need to be honored and they need to be
treated like people right now the
policing Community is getting a lot of
support a GoFundMe set up for the
officers families has raised more than a
hundred thousand dollars in its first 24
hours with the goal of raising at least
one hundred thousand dollars more pharah
Heather York's West in Edmonton thank
you heather
to Montreal next where a suspect is
under arrest after three people were
found stabbed to death in an apartment
building this morning
when police officers arrive on-site they
locate three victims of a such business
that the body was with violence marks
possibly persuaded by a sharp object
police say they arrested an individual
outside the building where the victims
were found no information about the
victims or their relationship to the
suspect has been released
Canada's federal police force has a new
top cop at least for now Deputy
Commissioner Michael dewham will lead
the RCMP as in trim head while the
search continues for a permanent
replacement for outgoing commissioner
Brenda lucky who retired from the force
today Mackenzie gray breaks down Lucky's
controversial Legacy and what it could
mean for the force moving forward
the mounties got their man at least
temporarily Mike duhammer announced as
the new interim commissioner of the RCMP
I can confirm a 34-year veteran of the
forest duhammer started his career as a
general assignment officer in Nova
Scotia and Rose through the ranks to
head the rcmp's policing Division I can
assure you that we are very much looking
at how to ensure
that the RCMP can continue to offer the
very best
service to Canadians as this grew and
there was more and more increased no
stranger to the spotlight to him testify
to the commission looking into the use
of the emergencies act and recently made
news at a committee looking into foreign
interference does that mean that the
operations from those illegally illegal
uh Beijing police stations have ceased
we are our understanding is a deceased
and we're continuing investigation of
the ongoing
to him takes the reins from outgoing
commissioner Brenda lucky who had a
tumultuous time as Canada's Top Cop
heavily criticized for handling of the
Nova Scotia mass shooting and alleged
political interference lucky also worked
Advocates on our view of systemic racism
after George Floyd's Murder By an
officer in Minnesota
systemic racism Rank and file mountie
struggled internally under lucky with
class action lawsuits leading the force
to pay over 125 million to 2300 women
who experience sexual harassment or
abuse while in the RCMP racist Behavior
sexist Behavior
is still prevalent in the RCMP you see
it in the news every day big factor in
the time the new commissioner will be
tasked with modernizing an institution
in its 150th year but with over 30 000
employees tasked with policing rural
highways to investigating terrorism the
mounties broad mandate makes meaningful
change challenging the Hem officially
starts his new job tomorrow after Brenda
Lucky's five-year term comes to an end
but despite knowing when she was going
to leave the Liberals have yet to put in
place a process or a timeline to appoint
a new full-time commissioner pharah
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie what did the Prime Minister as
Chief of Staff Katie Telford know about
election interference it's a question
that won't go away the federal
conservatives want Telford to testify
before a Commons committee and are set
to force a vote on the subject as early
as Tuesday our David Aiken is digging
deeper into the political implications
of all of this David this could test the
strength of the liberal NDP Alliance for
all the opposition parties want the PM's
Chief of Staff Katie Telford to tell
them what she knows about allegations
first reported by global news a
potential foreign interference in the
2019 and 2021 elections she knows all
the secrets it's time for her to come
forward and honestly testify about what
happened what was beijing's role in
supporting Justin Trudeau resuming
meeting number 57 but liberal MPS have
been filibustering and blocking
opposition attempts at the committee
stage to force Telford to testify so the
conservative are upping the ante and
will put the matter to a vote in the
House of Commons next week now if
Trudeau really wanted to stack the deck
in his favor to prevent telford's
testimony he would likely declare such a
vote to be a confidence matter so we
asked him will you make that a vote of
matter that vote a matter of confidence
but in a rambling two-minute long
response to our question well Trudeau
said Lots about the conservatives
everyone can see clearly that they are
more interested in political theater but
he never answered the question
and it is an important one because last
year the NDP signed a deal promising to
vote with the government on confidence
matters so long as the Liberals were
moving forward on NDP priorities like
Universal pharmacare and affordable
housing well the NDP themselves have
conceded that the Liberals are indeed
holding up their end of the bargain so
Trudeau should be able to assume that if
he declares the Telford motion to be a
matter of confidence the NDP will hold
up their end of the bargain and vote
against that motion blocking attempts to
force Telford to testify but the NDP do
want Telford to testify but do they want
that Telford testimony bad enough to
break that liberal ending agreement and
possibly precipitate a general election
well stay tuned this is some high-stakes
political poker and no one is tipping
their hand right now the debate on the
Telford motion is Monday the vote
follows on Tuesday pharah all right
David again in Ottawa thank you David
Canada has the fastest growing
population in the G7 and with that comes
unique challenges there are huge
backlogs in Housing Development and
Construction today the PM stopped in
wealth Ontario detailing how a four
billion dollar housing accelerator fund
will help create more affordable homes
the federal government will directly
fund municipalities that submit action
plans for funding the boldest plans
resulting in the most housing units
especially affordable units will be
rewarded
Judo says the funding pool first
announced in the federal budget will
help provide more money to local
governments and Fast Track the creation
of a hundred thousand new homes across
Canada the Prime Minister also says the
funding will help eliminate red tape by
accelerating approval timelines and by
freeing up unused land the application
portal for the fund opens in June now to
the banking turmoil that has investors
staring at their portfolios as stocks
tumble the TSX fell more than 150 points
today the Dow dropped by almost 400
points or a bit over a percent it has
been a wild week of trading fueled by
three bank failures that rippled through
financial markets forcing Regulators to
step in as Jackson prosco reports
investors are pulling back fearing the
U.S banking system is on the brink
California's First Republic Bank is the
latest lender to need a bailout after
Panic spread the bank's share price
dropped and customers started pulling
their deposits I was definitely
concerned with the financial situation
you know after the two Banks went under
late Thursday 11 of the largest banks in
the U.S swept in with a 30 billion
dollar Lifeline a rapid move to prevent
cascading failures across the financial
system so it is in the interest to make
sure that the system as a whole is
stable and that sort of motivates maybe
the way why they put the money into
these Banks the worry
a street is that it's not over yet
markets were down sharply shares of
mid-sized Banks were hit hard I think
there's a lot more we don't know than we
do know right and so we got the sense
that there will be further problems I
don't think this story is All Out There
are fears other American Banks may be
unstable or that nervous customers could
trigger another run if depositors rush
into a bank and want all their money out
at once they will force an otherwise
healthy Bank to close the trouble all
started one week ago with the collapse
of Silicon Valley Bank deposits there
were eventually guaranteed by the U.S
treasury Department svb formally filed
for bankruptcy Friday the Jitters have
since spread around the globe Credit
Suisse was forced to secure a 54 billion
dollar Lifeline from Switzerland's
Central Bank after its share price
plummeted further testing investor and
consumer confidence AS Global economies
Teeter on the brink of recession the
White House is now calling for tougher
regulation of the entire U.S banking
sector they want Congress to pass laws
that would strip Bank Executives of
their jobs and even their bonuses if
they engage in mismanagement
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
Ukraine's wish finally granted
coming up who's sending the nation
fighter jets as Russia's War rages on
the international criminal court has
issued an arrest warrant for Russian
President Vladimir Putin accusing him of
committing war crimes in Ukraine judges
say there are grounds to believe Putin
Bears personal responsibility for the
Abduction of children from occupied
areas of Ukraine to Russia Moscow is
rejecting the war and calling it
meaningless the ICC has no powers to
arrest suspects and can only exercise
jurisdiction within countries that are
signed up to its agreement
Slovakia has joined Poland in announcing
plans to send fighter jets to Ukraine
that's something Kiev has been pleading
for since the War Began but as Crystal
gemancing Reports Russia is playing it
down saying the donated Jets will be
destroyed
[Music]
a 21st century assignment for fighter
jets designed in the 70s and pressed
into service by the Soviet Air Force in
the 80s
these mix We are giving to Ukraine so
they can protect their civilians from
the amount of bombs that have been
hitting their homes and shelters where
civilians are dying Slovakia's
government approved the transfer of 13
mig-29s to Ukraine the Jets had been
grounded because of a lack of spare
parts and technicians to service them
Poland this week also finalized plans to
send four Jets what's that
you see it was just last month when
Ukraine's defense minister waved a
pocket square with a jet on it teasing
what he wanted from his NATO allies
but Russia also has friends China Xi
Jinping will spend three days in Moscow
next week the West has expressed fears
China would arm Russia and recently urge
she against such actions Germany
suggested China use its sway to convince
the Kremlin to withdraw from Ukraine
China will uphold its objective and fair
position on the Ukrainian crisis since
the spokesperson for the Chinese foreign
Ministry when it comes to Russia's war
in Ukraine Putin's advisers told a state
media Outlet Moscow highly appreciates
the balanced position of the Chinese
leadership Russia's full invasion of its
neighbor last year prompted Sweden and
Finland which shares a land border with
Russia to seek security under the NATO
Banner thank you after lengthy talks the
Turkish Parliament will start the
ratification process for Finland talks
continue on Sweden's bit turkey and
Hungary had previously blocked The Joint
NATO bid Hungary now says it will also
start the ratification process for
Finland Russia previously warned that it
would be forced to respond should NATO
set up military infrastructure along the
borders of the Nordic countries pharah
Chris look a man saying in London thank
you Crystal the pilots of two Russian
fighter jets that intercepted a U.S
drone this week will be given State
Awards Russia's defense minister praised
the pilots for preventing the Drone from
flying into an area Moscow had banned
for flights and repeated the kremlin's
version of events that its planes did
not make physical contact with the Drone
the Pentagon released a 40-second edited
video yesterday disputing that claim and
showing the sequence of events the U.S
military says Russian fighter jets
harassed the Drone and clipped its
propeller causing it to crash into the
Black Sea Washington calls it an unsafe
and unprofessional Intercept in
international airspace
[Music]
tempers flare in France ahead the fire
and the fury over proposed pension
reforms
[Applause]
fiery clashes between police and
protesters in Paris last night
demonstrators burned cars and garbage
Furious over France's wildly unpopular
pension overhaul
the outrage reaching a boiling point
after president Emmanuel Macau resorted
to special Constitutional Powers after
he didn't have enough votes to pass a
bill raising the retirement age from 62
to 64. McCall has argued the change is
necessary to keep France's pension
system intact but since the start of the
year the proposals triggered Nationwide
protests and multiple major strikes
in Pakistan an arrest warrant has been
suspended for former prime minister
Imran Khan who was ousted last year over
corruption allegations
reporters escorted Khan's vehicle to the
courts where he was granted protective
bail in multiple cases involving
terrorism corruption and conspiracy
charges Khan is due in court in
Islamabad tomorrow on political
corruption charges and this comes after
days of violent clashes between
supporters and police outside Khan's
home in Lahore where he has holed up and
avoided arrest
new information tonight adding to the
swirling debate about the origins of the
pandemic an international team of
scientists says newly released genetic
data links the origins of covid-19 to
raccoon dogs that were sold at a wet
Market
samples from the market in Wuhan China
were previously found to contain both
covid and human DNA but no animal DNA
after re-analyzing the data DNA from
raccoon dogs was found on some of the
coveted positive samples the discovery
does not prove that the virus jumped
from animals to humans but it is being
called the strongest evidence of that
theory to date last month a report from
the U.S energy Department concluded what
it called Low confidence that the virus
first spread as a result of a lab leak
[Music]
where everyone really does know your
name next big cheers in Canada's
smallest bar
[Music]
from the streets of Dublin packed tight
with Partiers to the rivers of Chicago
dyed green to Mark the occasion Irish
Pride was in the air in many countries
today and Canada of course celebrating
St Patrick's Day too with lots of pubs
filling up early for the festivities
bartenders across the country will
likely have their hands full tonight but
big crowds will not be a problem for one
mixologist in Guelph Ontario that's
because he tends the smallest bar in
Canada only taking reservations a
handful at a time there was Mike trolley
reports there's no shortage of good
times in this teeny tiny spot
anybody can mix a drink but how about
infusing cinnamon and smoke into a
decanter
standing room only isn't just a bar it's
a creative outlet for its resident
mixologist we wanted to speak easy we
wanted uh I wanted it to be showy I
wanted you know a little bit of Willy
Wonka some Dr Seuss a little bit of
Disney
you didn't want it to be a bar where
somebody walked in and said give me a
beer right right drinks aside Doug
Todd's stage is smaller than most his
vision came to life on a sliver of land
where Ontario and Arthur streets meet in
Guelph Ontario the actual bar is in a
corner of that sliver a spot so tiny he
and his partner Mike Watt had no idea
they were set to steal the title of
smallest bar in Canada from the 150
square foot alpacano in Montreal with
room to spare
143.8 square feet the point makes a
difference
nothing we're smaller than the other guy
and they're clearly proud of that with
the Cozy capacity of nine there was just
enough room for us when Elizabeth
Beverly Padia Del Marin and Sharon
showed up for an afternoon cocktail when
the bars called standing room only
there's no getting around it you're
gonna get to know everyone
hi ladies
[Applause]
seats are taken got a movie on over to
the end
hang out on the Dance Floor
yeah they have a dance floor and at
under four square feet are we on Todd
believes it's the smallest in the world
he leaves the dancing to others the
drinks are all him what do you call
yourself you're not a bartender no no
that's I had one guy one guy called me a
cocktologist
whoa okay indeed but when your cocktail
comes with a Twist absinthe Todd's dream
however small he sees it starts to come
into Focus taste that microlight Global
News Guelph Ontario
now room for introverts in there and
that's global national for this Friday
night I'm far right now sir thanks so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is
valdavid in Quebec until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
[Music]